Wow buzz can you believe it's been 20
years since you and I met in Andy's room
domain 20 years since you tried to
terminate me by pushing me out the
window in Andy's room oh come on
Baz I told you that was an accident
besides if it wasn't for me you'd still
be walking around like a clueless Space
Ranger
oh you're Buzz Lightyear I come in peace
to infinity and beyond really you're
going to mock me in front of 900 million
people at the Academy Awards was an
alienware remember woody if it wasn't
for me you'd still be walking around
like an old cowboy TV star hey howdy hey
you're my favorite deputy Yeah right
like the wind bullseye right all right
enough already
the nominees for animated reach socom
buzz you're right woody the nominees for
animated feature film are Shaun the
Sheep movie mark Burton Richard Starzl
anomaly sir Charlie Kaufman Duke Johnson
Rosa trap
boy in the world alais abreu when marty
was their hero masa yellow my Yasha
Yoshiaki mission work inside out feed
dr. Jonas Rivera and envelope folks
thanks guys
and the Oscar goes to inside out
is the first Oscar and second nomination
for Jonas Rivera the second Oscar and
eight combination for Pete docter who is
also nominated this year for original
screenplay for inside out he took home
his first Oscar in this
we are so lucky not just us but everyone
in this room because regardless of a
gold man or not we get to make stuff
right we do and on this film every
single storyboard every single frame cut
line of dialogue every single pixel was
done by the amazing artists we work with
that Pixar led by John Lasseter they
should be up here with us tonight we
love them along with our amazing cast
best cast ever assembled animated or
otherwise we love you we want to thank
our wives Amanda Michelle our kids this
film is really born from watching our
kids grow up which is not easy anyone
out there who is in junior high high
school working it out suffering there
are days you're going to feel sad you're
going to feel angry you're going to be
you're scared that's nothing you can
choose but you can make stuff make films
draw write it'll make a world of
difference